hello folks and welcome to today's
webinar uh the role of farms in
decentralized composting uh I'm Linda
bilson's brolis of the institute for
local self-reliance composting for
Community initiative and we're your
hosts for this uh webinar but also
joining me now is my colleague at issr
Megan Matthews she'll be helping uh keep
it helping us keep the webinar running
smoothly say hi say Hi Megan hi
everybody
Welcome awesome all right so while we're
waiting to uh for folks to finish
joining um are you all hearing that
feedback I'm gonna go ahead and turn off
my video just in
case okay
so uh for those of you that aren't
familiar with our work um issr is
composting for Community initiative is
advancing composting to reduce waste
enhance local soils create Community
Development opportunities and to protect
the climate our focus is to catalyze
distributed food waste composting
options that include home community and
on Farm scales and we work to promote
locally based composting in a number of
different ways uh we convene a national
Community composter Coalition and host
national uh cultivating Community
composting forums we work one-on-one
with communities through technical
assistance and policy support we produce
reports infographics and various
templates for composting sites uh we
host regular webinars and even a podcast
we also have a map that shows
initiatives around the US and the
policies and programs that are advancing
composting at this scale and uh Megan
will be at adding some links to the chat
for you to check some of that out but
you can also find uh all of these
resources on our
websites uh if you go to il.org
composting you'll see a composting
resources dropdown menu on the right
hand side of the screen and from there
you can select reports podcasts webinars
and
more uh we also offer Technical Training
through our neighborhood so Rebuilders
composter training program and for
anyone that's interested in more
training on uh the composting science uh
we released a self-paced online
community composting 101 certificate
course uh we released that earlier this
year uh the course covers composting
fundamentals and the ins and outs of
starting a community-based composting
project so if you're interested check it
out
there uh this webinar series is being
brought to you through our involvement
with the million acre challenge of which
ilsr is a founding member the million
acre challenge is a collaborative
project that is supporting farmers in
implementing healthy soils practices and
regenerative agriculture on 1 million
Acres of Farmland in Maryland and the
Chesapeake region by
2030 healthy soils uh healthy soils
practices including the skillful
production and use of compost on farms
uh have tremendous potential to improve
Farm resilience and profitability while
also providing critical ecosystem
services at a crucial time for our farms
and our planet to learn more about this
project check out
website and now uh let's get to know
each other with a few interactive
polls all righty so first question where
are you participating from select one of
the following Northeastern us Southern
us Midwestern us Western us or outside
the
US
right and let's see the
results so as usual majority from the
northeastern us but we got a good
showing from the midwestern us um and
even good representation from other
parts of the US and outside so welcome
to everyone uh let's go to the next
poll
what best describes your affiliation
select one of the following are you a
farmer a
composter uh someone who represents a
government uh are you a researcher Farm
service provider or
nonprofit or are you in uh a different
business just a few more seconds
all right let's check it out so very
nice even mix of farmer composter a
little head uh a lead to the government
folks and a researcher Farm service
provider and nonprofit I know that's a
big category other business so welcome
to you all and the final poll that we'll
do are you currently involved in
composting or supporting compost in your
work and the second answer is supposed
to be no not
now okay just a couple more
seconds great let's check it
out so vast majority are already either
composting or involved with composting
so welcome to you all and for those that
are not currently doing it uh hopefully
this presentation will inspire you to to
get involved awesome thanks
Megan so
um now uh as we hand over controls to
our first presenter uh a few
housekeeping notes um everyone is in
listen only mode uh we will have time at
the end of both presentations for
question questions uh but go ahead and
enter any questions you have as they
come up in the go-to webinar control
panel box on your screen this webinar is
being recorded and a copy will be sent
to you within the next day or so so no
worries there but now it's my pleasure
to introduce our first presenter Florian
amlinger he is an a agronomist and
Engineering consultant at compost
Consulting and design in Austria he's
contributed to Austria's decentralized
network of 350 or more composting
facilities through applied research and
the development of organic Source
separation and composting systems in
various communities including in rural
areas that depend on farms floran
coordinated the technical specification
in Austria's compost ordinance and
represents Austria and the Austrian
compost and biogas Association in
European collaborations the welcome
floran take take us
away so Linda thank you very much I hope
you can hear me now if not just make a
remark or Give Me A Sign because it is
very good it asked me for a new hardware
there but I will click it off here and
so off we go
um I'm very happy to be with you I would
L like to be together live with you best
way on a composting plant or on a farm
where we can do the work
together um there is a philosopher uh uh
from the last century and he
said a very nice little
sentence that the experience of the ey
of
myselfself is only possible in the
encountering the you so encountering the
world if it a human being if it is the
nature or some part of the nature
oh if it
is the soil maybe if it is a compost te
it is a personal getting personal
getting involved
really with my knowledge with all my
biography with all my
skills with all my feelings and my
emotions with all I have learned in my
life uh in a NeverEnding learning
process as you know um in organic
farming uh in the very beginning of the
uh installation or founding of the
International Federation of the organic
farming movements
I they implemented this famous sentence
healthy soil means healthy plants means
healthy animals and healthy
man but then it took us some time and
still takes our time to Define what is
health
really and we more and more come to the
conclusion that is a
very
volatile very
Dynamic
status um uh depending on the
circumstances that change from second to
second from minute to minute so it is a
balance we have to
achieve and soil fertility is
uh constant work to keep the balance on
a level in the soil in the soil plant
system that is
providing fertility and health to the
entire ecosystem we are part of
it um and then I come to another
citation from Johan wolf gangur I'm
sorry I don't have uh citations from
um from American Authors
here but he says this is a translation
of myself but that's not the good one
but the meaning is as long as you don't
have
understood uh the relationship or the
dynamic between death and creation death
and growth death and birth you're just a
dull guest on the dark Earth and this is
all about this is these big
microbiological microbio
micrum Dynamic we are living in we have
been developing out in our
Evolution that we have to understand
steeper and steeper how we are connected
and what is is all about is what we see
here it is the Garden it is the paradise
that feeds us and it feeds us because
there is a
miracle there's a miracle that's deep
under our feet there are the rocks and
what is the main property in relation to
what we see as a green entity on the
top it is
dead it doesn't create on its own what
we call Life what we call development
due to the laws which are you know
introduced into the sub substance
itself and how does it come that such a
you know plant on the top I didn't bring
my carrot from the garden now how does
it come that on on the mineral ground of
our Earth such a
beautiful uh Empire of
plants that's is nourishing us can
evolve how does it work so there must be
something that is transforming the dead
Rock the scent the desert into something
which is very close to life and this
miracle is
mainly can be named by a key word and
this is
symbiosis and this is a symbiosis
between the plant and the mineral
Empire below the soil
and that is what is in between and that
is soil and this is a habitat for the
microbiome the soil
microbiome symbiosis is
everything and the plant with the plant
exudates nourishes the microbiome in the
root
sphere
by you know giving the assimilates the
phytosynthesis products directly into
the soil to feed the the symbiotic
microorganisms in their environment in
order to get them as part of their organ
of the plant
organ as we can name the soil as an
organ of the
plant to deliver the minerals and the
mineral compounds to nourish again the
plant it's a big you know Wonder Miracle
of symbiosis and interaction As We Know
master of symbiosis just symbolizing
this
picture and I say this
only because this fungal and bacterial
life in
soil
boosts life on Earth tremendously yeah
plants May absorb just as one example 16
times more water and nutrients with the
help of the fungal weap in the soil full
stop it's just one small indication
there's much more to say about what has
been found up out in the recent
years and the key is that this habitat
this environment of the plant is this
clay humus complex and
now the I come to the agricultural
composting or the corporation of the on
Farm
composting that this processes in the
soil
and the idea the ideas behind creating
maintaining building up enhancing soil
fertility must be understood by heart
intimately by the farmers who are
responsible for the soil for their
grandchildren this is all they have to
do soil is a common is not private
property no square meter no square yard
of soil belong to anybody it belongs to
everybody in order to preserve life on
Earth it's a very simple attitude and
what we are have to take care about is
this humification dynamic in the
soil this is one
example from a long-term experiment in
Europe showing that aggregate stability
by
using composted manure over 21 years
increases the aggregate stability
against you know conventional soil
management
tremendously and there's also one thing
one
motivation I want to
mention they have found out that we have
to eat 24 apples to
to uh receive the same
amount for instance
of uh
iron um compared to
1914 where it was only necessary for the
same amount to eat one e so something
went wrong in terms of
degradation of the quality of food so
whus
management so fertility management is a
matter of food safety and therefore what
we need is education education
education and it is education to from
the gardeners who are responsible for
you know self-reliant Gardens and food
provision for the families and the
communities learning all about the
different processes from Bashi biochar
composting and the composting process
itself all possibility of variations
which are part of our
natural
bio I would say bios symbiosis in our
environment and with Farmers because the
farmers are the professionals here and
the concept in Austria was from the very
beginning in all
provinces in
1980s every village is composting farmer
in order to close the organic cycle
Village by Village City by city but
therefore the farmers have to be
motivated have to
understand the maintenance and how to
take care about the organic fertility of
their of their soil with the help of
compost of the Recycled organic metal
they have to understand what can go
wrong in terms of drying out and the
composting process they have to
understand what kind of materials they
have how to mix it in the right way to
understand that humus formation on soil
and in the natural environment in the
Savana in the woods uh on aable end is
not the same as in a composting heat it
is an imitation of this process but it
is not the same they have to learn
exactly what time of Shredder material
they need and depending on the type of
body material they have available the
machines have to develop in a way that
the structure the size the particle size
and the threading properties are perfect
for composting specifically to create
the right surfaces for the
microbiota so training training
training uh and to get specifically the
hands on and I show you only those
figures what we in Austria in these
training programs
um we have approximately 280 Farmers
running composting plants out of 400
composting plants in total I will show
you the figures
later we tell them something which is
very important and this is a
teaching from my experience since since
the 1980 this is key what I've
understood of soil formation there is no
stable humus formation without clay in a
pure silicate Sandy situation sand
desert situation without clay formation
you will never achieve a stable humus
layer never
ever so you need clay compounds during
the composting process to stabilize the
clay humus complexes you
produce and then we train them even a
little bit about indicators they can
easily test on Farm in order to have an
idea not only by organoleptic
observation but also by some very simple
tests on the nitrogen cycle on pH on
sulfate Etc and also Crest test I will
show you later in order to see uh the
stage of maturation that is very
important to achieve a compost
that
contributes best possible to humus build
up in the
soil so this is Crest test that is done
or with other plants also that is done
routinely with the farmers and also this
dilution test with just with distilled
water where you can see from the density
from um the transparency and also from
the colors the maturity of your compost
and the performance of your composting
facility it's just a little bit of
training for a proper
interpretation and then at the very end
what you see here on the
top I can show you here I guess this
is the right one uh uh what you see on
the top here is the uh composta and the
quality seal the quality certification
for composting
plans um and the some minimum uh
criteria they have to achieve in order
to participate uh to be awarded for the
certification and what is sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry now it's going on now
I come to collection what is very
important if you receive not only green
waste and manure from the environment
but also kitchen waste and you know from
households and from restaurants is the
issue of impurities big problems in
cities but it very much depends on the
collection scheme so in the best
performing on Farm
composting corporations where also the
farmers do the collection service for
the
municipalities they achieve a purity or
a contamination of only
1.2% if they do it in a way I will show
you in a minute
and this success story where you have
nearly nothing left because you have
educated household by household in the
schools in the households in the
commercial entities Etc providing the
right equipment you achieve very very
high Purity because what you see here is
a big problem if you screen it you will
have impurities and your compost Market
might be destroyed at once
so all of our citizens receed these
little vented buckets Ramon will tell
you maybe about this also later this is
standard in well
performing uh circumstances situations
all over
Europe paper bags biodegradable bags
which are certified by European
standards for garden waste the bigger
paperbacks um where you can put uh the
grass and and clippings and some leaves
Etc and
flowers and it is collected by farmers
in the rural environment in this way for
instance uh depending on the size of the
household the buckets are bigger or
smaller but every bucket bucket has a
name and is identified even the
biodegradable BS in some areas are
identified with a number so if there are
a lot of impurities Plastics and some
forks and metals and so included not
well separated they can identify the
household and contact him and tell him
you're not committed in the way we need
it you're part of our society and please
take
care with bigger facilities with pickup
systems um hydraulic systems so
depending on the size and uh the
catchment
area collection system is different here
we have a example of a city of grats
with more than 300,000 inhabitants and
they decided to do a centralized
collection prepare and purify the
collected biow waste kitchen waste and
garden waste in a central treatment
facility put it on a truck and send it
to 18 different different compost
agricultural composting plants to
farmers in the environment U maximum 80
kilm in average 30 kilm 10 to 30 kilm in
the vicinity in the environment of the
city so there is no Central bit uh
composting plant but 18 onine composting
plants and when the compost is tested
for the standard quity criteria like
heavy metals Etc and everything is okay
the farmer takes over the compost for
his own use or he can also sell the
compost to whomever he likes so it is a
win-win situation for the city for the
municipality and for the
farmer yes this is the typical uh Garden
waste collection and then we have
collection points not uh the distance
between the settlements and these
collection points should not be more
than 5 kilm so and in a mostly connected
with a recycling center this a public
imunity site where people pass by
frequently uh easy to access with a
separation of fine and bulky Garden
waste so that bulky Garden waste can be
shreded and it's mostly uh can be
delivered for free so the system yeah
and now I show you typical composting
plants on Farm composting plants from
very small
um uh one wind row alongside uh the
field alongside the road in the
countryside where he goes with the wind
roll Turner alongside the little road
here on the upper left
side uh it is composting between 300 and
10,000 cubic met depending on the mment
area and the municipality involved
um most of the facilities yeah can have
to be built on a paved area I will show
you later uh details on on
this uh exactly this is an overview of a
design of a composting
plant where you have H rotter there this
is the main rotting area on the top this
is sealed this is paved the surface B
water is collected into the Wastewater
retention tank that is to be calculated
according to the participation and the
rainfall
seasons in agreement with uh the um
local authorities and the experts from
the licensing
bodies and all facilities must be
licensed as any even commercial waste
treatment facility under
the
specific regulations and guidelines
National guidelines for composting in
Austria though there is no difference if
you're a farmer or a commercial entity
or industrial Farm you have to follow
the same rules in terms of Environmental
Protection and then the open the the the
post roting or the maturation can be
done on open ground there is no need for
cealing and the definition for uh uh the
maturation phase is that the compost
must um achieve or maintain a
temperature below 40 to 45 degre Celsius
on a constant level and then you can put
it on the open ground or even beside
your acre or your field where you uh
finish your composting for the final
period in
met so this is also what those Farms
look
like
typically yeah Wastewater collection
with those little
gullies
uh uh yeah
and I I uh swiftly give an overview what
is needed in terms of um regulatory
framework in order to establish even
this decentralized on Farm
Corporation first of all in order to
make the entire system of separate
collection and composting successful you
need an obligation of binding targets
for sour
separation uh this has been established
already in the early 90s in Austria and
then it starts the education how this
must be done in order to achieve uh at
the end a high quality compost so high
quality feed stock means high quality
compost uh in order to give time and
skills and knowledge to set up the right
collection
scheme um in in parallel we have a ban
on biodegradables of landfills so that
all so separated Organics are directed
towards biological
treatment and then it is important to
give compost a name a name as a product
that means in Austria we were the first
country or EU member states establishing
a so-called endof waste quality
standards within a decree within an
ordinance that defines the eligable feed
stock feed stock quality plus minimum
requirements for you know time
temperature regime hygienization
sanitization plus the definition of
quality criteria for compost two c
the waste status to become a compost
product to be freely marketed and put on
the
marketplace and therefore this was an
enormous achievement to say this is a
product as a fertilizer as a soil
improver as a constituent for growing
media that can compete with all other
fertilizers growing media and and soil
improver uh the next one is we need
technicals standards common technical
standards for
design and for operation of composting
plants that's very important not to be
too strict and not to overrule with too
you know
scary and and strict and stringent
requirements regarding environmental
requirements we can discuss this perhaps
later what I mean with this this is
about order control this is about water
protection Etc
um where if you if you make a good job
you can be quite relaxed with a
composting
activities um economic drivers
incentives this is mainly an
issue uh to make separate collection
give incentive for separate collection
and make residual waste expensive but
this is not so much our topic
here
um and also of course to maybe give some
support which was done in the in the
beginning and now by the EU for
establishing the centralized on Farm
composting systems where provinces and
also national government and
municipalities gave uh subsidies for the
investment up to 50% for the investment
for building and construction of the
composting
plants uh and finally the quality
assurance and ification scheme we have
established since very
beginning here uh the
developments from the
1990s to today and you will wonder uh in
in 1992 these obligation for separate
collection of organic waste was
established from that on the
municipalities and waste management
association started the initiatives so
there's a big increase in the next
uh three to four years and then
constantly more and more
was produced uh in terms of of quantity
of bowte collected and you see a miracle
in from 2017 to
2019 this is because uh we established a
uh
national uh um regulation for Waste
reporting for electronic data management
in waste reporting now we have really
good
data the data the the the really the
reality of separate collection
specifically of um of greenbase Etc
chumped into the statistics so from 2017
to
2019 it it's went up from approximately
1 million to 1.6 million tons we are
collecting uh I didn't mention that we
have approximately 8 million inhabitants
in Austria so that you have that
relation at the
moment and you can uh achieve a picture
of our decentralized system that we have
for these 8 million uh residents or
inhabitants 400 composting plants um
that means the average um treating
approximately 1.3 million
tons uh and including some sewage LGE
here and this is in total 14 5 kilg per
inhabitant that is
fact yeah composted that's a very high
number
actually and uh nearly 70% are members
in the quality assurance scheme and now
is something very important that our um
the Novation the new
composting um ordinance that will be
enacted next year will make the quality
assurance and certification scheme
including intensive education and
certification obligatory so the 70% from
next year or in two years time there be
100% so those composting facilities all
Farms will be visited every year by an
inspector and by this they receive
training and Improvement year by year
year by year and uh this is a very
important tool to integrate this
intensive communication
controlling and inspection work and it
creates also
confidence
among uh among the society among the
authorities uh but also for the
population and you see our small scale
composting plants in average we have uh
here 3,000 tons per per
plant uh in the top of Austria or in the
center of Austria there's one province
uh they established approximately 160
composting plants for 1.4 million
inhabitants in a very rural area so
there it has been realized what I
mentioned before every city every
village every town one or two farmers
yeah doing the job of separate
collection on
composting this is the most
transparent uh and uh way to do it
because every citizen knows exactly
where the compost is produced the
quality and where he received his
compost for his garden
again but the participation in separate
collection depends very much first on
Public Relation work on the roll out
system of the bioin of the brown bin but
also on of course the settlement
structure more rural so we have
different Pro if it's more rural or more
urban areas so we have quite a
difference between different provinces
but one of the provinces uh the far
right one with 10% participation in fact
is the province that we would say is a
white spot in Austria so I have still a
lot to do
there you see the same it is Corinthia
this is the quantity in the specific
quantity Collective here in 2017
kilogram per inhabitant and year and you
see uh kinia here the the second left
only 50 kilg per
inhabitant uh if you compare it with
others up to 117 some other provinces
but in some districts the quantity goes
up to 200 300 kilogram per inhabitant
there's a huge potential still available
in spite we have started in the late
80s and what is now very important is
again coming back to education or to
minimum
requirements is that uh there is a
strict rule that if you have to mix in a
certain amount of bulky
shredded wood waste into kitchen waso
into sewage sledge so this is um a very
you know a a an element of quality
assurance that has been put up first as
a guideline and in due time next year it
will be an obligation for the license
and you
prevent uh
mismanagement all the problems and
failures on composting plant if you
strictly require a certain minimum
requirement for the initial mix of the
feed stock that you have enough carbon
Rich material and this becomes important
also in terms of understanding the
composting process from the very
beginning uh identifying the right
composition of each stock and another
issue that we have a minimum requirement
because all our facilities or most of
them yeah
95% of our facilities are open wial uh
composting plants that we want to
prevent these you know 4 meter high uh
Table
Mountains and uh provides minimum
requirements
for the relation between size of the
wind R and minimum requirements for
turning and
Aviation
so feed stock
mix um uh limiting the size of the windr
plus turning and ariation as minimum
[Music]
requirements and if this is already not
only in a guideline but in a binding you
know setup
Bing uh component element in the
National liing procedure it is also
educating the authorities and the
experts in the authorities and in the
local
governments and this is another very
important message that education is need
needed for all involved parties not only
for the composting plant operators and
between the experts no you have to take
on board the local government and the uh
representative of the authorities which
are involved in the licensing and in the
control and this is just the scheme of
the uh quality
assurance system where all um composting
plants and this was very important for
the farmers are obliged to be
members um so they have one person
visiting them taking the
samples um um providing the report from
the accredited laboratory and there is
an independent committee that would
speak out on a the certificate year by
year so every composting
plants receives such a
certificate uh he can use for his
marketing and is is well known and
accepted by all professional uses and in
the
markets that's another example how this
is done on a European level also there's
a intensive cooperation with the
European compost Network and we
personally in our Institute we also
provide International certification for
countries who do not have the
infrastructure for certification of
compost and every second year there is a
big yester big celebration where the
best 10 composting composts are awarded
with the so-called
composta uh that are tested for the
parameters I showed you before or you
will see them when you receive the
presentation and finally but finally
education
internationally and don't know I I'm
used all my time more than my time I
guess
already um uh you see uh after the
Corona and covid break I'm happy to
offer again this autumn in September an
international one week uh training uh uh
and uh and training and study tour in
Austria where we try to show you the
details um
uh of the composting separate collection
scheme specifically in the the
decentralized model which is quite
unique in Europe and I would say
worldwide but I'm very happy it's not
worldwide anymore that we have it uh
with Ramon's activities and his friends
and um I'm very happy to see and hear
your efforts in the US I would be more
than happy to visit once in near
future all right thank you very much if
you want to hear more about uh this this
seminar and this uh Excursion in
September I will put you in my address
list and send you the information thank
you so much and I'm looking forward for
our
discussion wonderful thank you so much
Florian uh for that great presentation
um and uh in the interest of time I'm
going to save uh the questions for the
very end like to make sure we have time
for Ramon's presentation though we do
have a few good questions uh please keep
them coming if you have
them um but now as we hand uh controls
over to Ramon uh I will go ahead and
introduce him so Ramon Plana uh hold a p
PhD in biology and Industrial composting
and is an international consultant with
Maestro
composor he has worked with private and
public entities around the world to
advance research design and imple
implementation projects for the
management and treatment of a variety of
organic waste he holds several patents
for the treatment of organic waste
through aerobic and anerobic biological
processes and regularly collaborates
with the association of cities and
regions for sustainable resource
management so take us away
Ramon okay hello there hello everyone
just a second okay I think that you are
seeing my screen
now so hello everyone thank you very
much to the els for the invitation to to
be part of the of this
webinar and uh I I think that now you
are going to understand why at the
beginning I asked to to Linda that
floran has to talk before me because
what we are going to to show you what I
going to present you is a much more
modest uh implementation of the fun
composting of the decentralized
composting model related to to farms and
the first steps that we are developing
here in Spain so that's either just you
have it if you want to know who I
am here in Spain we are uh defending
that the bowte management should have
three models or
three first
approaches the model without collection
of the food waste needed
Transportation the models were okay
there is a collection but the
transportation is minimum you don't go
very far from the town from the village
from the city and the centralized models
that are based on collection and
transportation to big facilities to be
uh plants treatment
plants the first two
models we think that can be done with
very simple and economical technology
low cost low tax system but as floran
said we need a very clean by ways with
very low content in contaminants of in
properties those systems are low Tech
because we need people so we are going
to rise the employment rates if in the
area we we change equipments for jobs
they are effective if we do it well it
allows to reach successful results and
we have many to present and what we
think that is more important is that
involve citizens because people is going
to see in front of them what is
happening with their wasted especially
with the fot waste with the kitchen
waste and what it means the quantities
what it means why they do not separate
it well and the possibilities to form
that way into a resource so at the end
the territory is also involved in the
management moreover we can't involve
local companies small companies small
and medium companies and even those
companies with social Enterprises that
allow that uh people in risk of social
exclusion could perform specific task
that are related in one way or another
with the composting with the local
composting so we think that with this
system you can develop a real local
economy circular Economy based in the
treatment of the kitchen ways or and
other kinds of uh organic
wastes the centralized models that uh we
are looking for big facilities with high
technology that allow us to treat food
waste or any other kind of organic waste
with a lot of contaminants uh we don't
care too much for the collection systems
there are automatic most of most of the
of the system so the employment rate is
much lower than in the others the
results are mixed in the meaning that in
some cases we have very good results and
they those
facilities produce a relatively good
product but in others it's a complete
disaster and uh they are distance to the
people it mean that people do not care
about what happens with the waste they
only care for the container that they
have
uh in front of their house or not far
from from their house that it has to be
empty every night that's just what they
they care for so with that in mind now
we are going to to travel from the US to
Spain I choose Detroit because it was
the first city I visit when the first
time I went to to the us and we are
going to the north of Spain to the city
of
bilau and here I we are going to present
you the first examples but before that
just a
few few hints about Spain and our Waste
Management uh results okay this is the
LA the the last results or the last uh
numbers we have about the municipal
waste management so as you can see most
of our municipal waste goes to lfi
directly to lfi it is a same and we have
have a lot of work to do to fulfill all
the European directives about Waste
Management we are in the queue and as
you can see at the at the left of the
graph for composting and anerobic
digestion we just recover the 3% of the
of the waste of the municipal waste
maybe you can you can find in in some
reports and some articles that the
number is around 17 why because they
considered that all the food waste that
are mixed with the residual waste so I
mean those fractions that that not
separate on SES and that go to
Mechanical biological treatment
facilities it's also
composting but in the real reality the
the quantity of food waste that is
recovered separately it's just the 3% so
as I said we have a lot of things to do
in this in this
country about the distribution of
population it is interesting to
understand what is happening here you
can see in this map of Spain a
distribution of the population and every
Spike you are seeing there are points
with a higher density than than others
so you can see the main cities of Spain
the center you can see this is the
capital Madrid here in the Mediterranean
Coast is Barcelona and all the
municipalities around the north this is
bilau and other other cities and
Sebastian
and this is Valencia and you can see
okay this is the big or the capitals of
the province of different states in
results 50% of the population of Spain
lives in 125 municipalities and we have
more than 8,000 municipalities in in in
Spain so half of the of the population
of this country it's distributed it's
dispersed in the
countryside and our Waste Management
model is in most of our region is
completely centralized this is the
number of mbts facilities as I said
before this is with not separation of
the food
was you can see the the this bar is a
comparison between different regions and
you see most of them are in Barcelona in
Catalonia in the South and Del Lucia
there are
Madrid if we talk about composting for
food waste for biow Waste you can see
that there's a big difference Catalonia
and the
rest why because here in Catalonia we
have around 27 composting facilities for
food waste and in the rest of of Spain
this is is an emptiness because the
north we have here we have we have two
now we have one in the B country we have
uh another one in in Nar and now we are
building two more Madrid have just uh
one of uh here in my homeland Gala in
the Northwest here we just have at this
moment one that is operating there are
another that are private but public that
is just one so as you can see the
different is huge what it means that if
we're trying to compare the uh
centralized models and the centralized
models I did this this number according
to the to the number of of composting
facilities in different countries in
Europe and the inhabitants as you can
see Portugal it has a composting
facility for every five Millions vers
the Spain is one composing facility for
every 1.5 million but if we take out
Catalonia it this number rise to more
than three
millions one composed facility for every
three millions person at the bottom
Austria as you have now listened to fan
and you can understand what they meaning
uh my numbers was around one composting
facility for every 19 uh inhabitants
floran Now update that data to 22,000
but as you can see see the big
difference okay the different approach
to the strategy of Waste Management the
centralized models confronting front
centralized models like Spain and
talking about another uh models like
houseold composting there are some areas
in the north where there are many
composter distributed in the in the
households but uh at the end not all of
them have been really monitored so we
don't really know they're being well
managed or not if they are uh processing
all the food waste that is being
generated in the household or not so
this number have to be taken with cus
and Community composting okay here we
have uh two regions that there are the
the main leaders at this moment this is
in the north Bas country was here they
were the Pioneers in in the meaning that
around 13 14 years ago we begin to
experiment with different municipal with
the different models that could be
implemented in in in their towns and
Village and nowadays there are more than
500 Community composting areas and 13
different models of community composting
here in the west this is the province of
poned this is where I was born and here
we there is a a model with a very um in
intensive program about decentralized
composting basic on community composting
and nowadays they are treating almost
3,500 tons of food waste per year in
community composting areas and there are
some areas in in the in the east in in
the community of Valencia there are some
initiatives Navar it's now also in the
Northeast they beginning with a very
intensive project and some areas of
Catalonia they have a very interesting
developing of community composting in
the rest there are also there are other
experience but there are not
Alternatives real alternatives to bowte
management so they need to have a
complimentary system with a collection
so this is the overview of Spain and our
Waste Management model and now I'm going
to present you the different
examples we go to the North La
lichu uh those were the Pioneers in in
the farm composting in
Spain here this is a small
Village of larab betu it's close to to
bilau around 20 kilom far it has uh
around 2,000
inhabitants and as they were about 20
kilometers far from from the big city in
the area it means that they have to pay
for the collection taxes and the
transportation cost this uh uh higher
prices than than the neighbors because
they were at the end of the valley so
the tracks have to go there collect a
few kilograms of food waste and then
come back to the big facility so for
this Village it means a lot of money so
in
2013 uh some neighbors here begin to
think that some other options could be
available for them and they have heard
something about the Austrian model here
in Spain it's uh you can some in some
places you can you can listen that the
that sentence Oh we have to replicate
the Austrian model or you have to look
for the Austrian model so Florian so
explain you what we think what is the
Austrian model so they wanted to do
something like that they contact me and
we were thinking about which were the
real possibilities for then to to
perform some kind of local composting
based in the action of local
farmers so nowadays you're going to see
we develop a A system that they are been
running during all these years that uh
at this moment involve 290 families nine
big producers big producers I mean uh
shops
restaurants um Fresh Markets in the area
and they have at this moment three
simple composting facilities that
managed by by Farmers uh a few months
ago they were four but now
the one of the farmers uh decided that
he couldn't continue with with with the
program as you see
these composting areas they are very
very
simple they were made by the by the
neighbors and with recycled materials so
the boots that you can see here they
were
recycled and the system is very very
simple it's Bas it in the three or four
boxes that when one is full they have to
move the material to the next and
continue and as you can see this is more
or less how it looks
why we can do it like that Florian also
explain it we have a very very good
quality of the foot waste it have less
than 1% of contaminants even we can
think about less than
0.5 so it's extremely easy to treat it
here you
have uh some videos where you can see
how the the system works okay so the fot
waste is generated in the households so
they collected in a very small
then three days during the week they can
take it out to the street to to the
doors of the building or the house and
then the the farmer the basara is the
the war in in Bas
language
collected okay at the beginning they
have just one one farmer and they they
realized that it was impossible to keep
the the service during the world year so
they look for other to join the the
program and at this moment as I say they
they are three so they they distribute
when and how they they collect the the
food waste every week in the composting
facility they measure the quantity of
the food waste by volume and they uh
just put it inside the inside the boxes
they add the the bulky material that
they have from their activity in in the
farm and from that the beginning the
process begin as you know at the end
they use Farmers really want the compost
for for the crop plants because the the
lands in that area are quite poor in
infertility because of industrial
activity that they had in in the area in
the previous year and those vegetables
are sold to the to the to the neighbors
to the population so they they close the
cycle during these
years ER what the they got
is the as I said the uh the they see
that it was impossible to keep the the
service if they don't have more than two
or three Farmers involved
because any injur of the of the farmer
got ill or he wants to take up a
holidays a vacation anything they want
to do they couldn't take the the
population un attended so they begin to
involve other Farmers they begin to try
with other
system as I said they were the Pioneers
so they were experimenting a lot with
these typical home composters for the
first stages and then they move it to
the
next and one of the most interesting
things here was that in
2015 one of the most important
restaurants in Spain one of with three
Michelin star one of those restaurants
that they give you uh a this like this
and the quantity of food is like this
and the bill is three pages at least and
have no less than two zos so one of
those restaurants joined the project and
it was very very funny because here you
have the composting area the first one
and it's around less than a mile far
from the from the uh from the town from
larab betu and the restaurant it's just
here really really close to the
composting area but they just wanted
more and more F waste beans they didn't
want to know nothing about compost until
the moment that the tong Hall decide
okay this is the bill for all the
containers that you're asking for and if
you don't want to pay it you have to
take your food waste and go to the
composting area and uh put it there for
to be processed and they wanted to say
okay we will do it and moreover they
begin to announce in the in the press
and in their web their web page that
they were making compost and at this
moment uh two years ago they got an
international prize award related to the
was the most sustainable restaurant in
the world because they were performing
composting and other things of course
but since then moment the pro here you
can see this is the restant here at the
bottom of the compos facility and since
that moment the the project got more uh
strength and it was more respected uh
for the local
authorities this is the quantities of uh
food waste that they are processing in
in this model okay here in the yellow
ones you can see this is from the
restaurant this is the quantity from the
restaurant
20202 because of the copy the quantities
was more smaller as you can see more
they processing 70 to little more than
80 tons per per year that's quite uh
modest this these are are the results
from the analytics of the first compost
they complies all the exigencies that we
have here in Spain for the for compost
and it has the highest legal quality
related to the heavy metals content is
Class A so here it Spain it will be
available to use in organic farming pros
and cons of the project okay it came
from the citizens that was very
important because it give you a a high
resistance and citizens convince the
authorities that it was good that it was
uh it has a future and at the end all
the Mayors accept it and and and bet the
that it could be a future for for the
for the town
it gives you a rent to the to the
farmers so they allow it to continue
their activities families are encouraged
to participate it because they really
know what happens with the wasted and
they know they are for good and not just
for them for all the population it's
simple it's a very simple system and
they could incorporate new incentives in
in the area like social
currency problems that as I said they
began in 2013 now we are 10 years later
they are still with the same uh model so
they have to improve it yet and they
will take it they have to invest more
money to to get all the all the efforts
and all the permits that the authorities
act the uh Regional authorities ask them
to have and they have a big dependence
of the number of of
farmers okay now we go very not far from
here in in the North surville
and here we have also the
first
composting uh facility that are really
managed by a farmer it is a a bigger
town and here we have we find household
composting Community
composting and with the for the families
that do not perform one of those systems
they have doorto door collection and
what they're doing now is they're taking
part of that to toor collection and
going to a
farmer here where they receive two tons
of bowte every 15 days so he's not under
pressure he can manage them with calm
and do all the things they have to be
done to be be sure that you have a good
compost they have a a small Turner
machine that was also made in
Spain and the bulky material is is
provided by the municipality and also by
the
farmers all the farmers were trained and
they have a very specific protocol for
the manage M of food waste so when the
TRU arrives they they are prepared to to
process immediately all the food waste
and build the
windro perform the turnings and to keep
it covered and under control at at every
moment so all the parameters are
monitored uh not uh at every moment but
yes every day we have the register of
temperatures or and either they have any
any problem they find or they sense any
smell or anything they immediately take
note and and and try to correct it and
before the use the product is analyzed
so all authorities can have the can be
sure that we are not doing anything
harmful for the environmental or for the
final destination of the
compost we are still in the north this
is a project uh that was Finance
financed by the European union and the
government of naar that involve a social
company that called HOSA we are here in
the
north here HOSA is a is a social company
that uh been uh working for 20 years now
and they produce
organic uh herbals medicinal medicinal
herbals and teas and different kinds of
cosmetic products all made by by organic
products uh locally and the the workers
are always people at risk of social
exclusion so one of the problems that
they had is what they didn't have enough
compost for their Harvest so they begin
to think after some of our uh meetings
and speechs in the University here in
Nar that maybe it could be possible that
they uh do perform the collection of
foot w in their area and with that food
waste they're going to produce compost
for themselves so they will have an
economical income for the service that
they offer to the to the to the towns
around the their
Farm the collection of the food waste
and the treatment of the food waste and
they have also the benefit of the
compost that they're going to produce
for their their use so here you have
it's a very simple composting facility
the they perform the biow collection to
for the local and they they do the local
treatment also with a very simple T
machine that was made locally with a
black by a blacksmith in the town but
also in this project we include the
training so this this facility is also a
school a school for training people as
uh Master composters as people that they
they they learn how what they have to do
technically I'm I'm Miss administrative
about the management of a composting
facility they also learn about the
compost how they can use it to take to
test the quality of the compost and also
schools and universities goes there to
learn more about composting another
point of this project is that the
university is related with it in the
research of different organic products
that can be produced in the composting
facility not only compost by by itself
we not a a liquid organic
fertilizers or different mixes of
products Bop pesticides Etc so there's
also a research here and broadcasting we
also we've been working a lot to promote
this model to make people know about it
so we try
to to make it more popular in in in
other areas of Spain last year we
received an award from the rural
Inspiration Awards for resilient food
future so we think that we were going in
the right way here another example now
we're going to the to the isand we go to
Bic Iceland and this is a project that
connect tourists with ecology and local
farming we are in the mayorca island in
the Mediterranean Sea here okay some
fast details you see you know here the
the problem with organic matter in the
soil in the Mediterranean Basin is
really really terrible we have have most
of our soils more than 75% of our soils
have less than 2% of organic matter and
we are even losing and losing that those
contents for the island you can see that
specifically they have six more almost
70% of the soils have an erosion risk
and they are losing almost 12 tons of
soil peror and per year in the island so
they need organic matter moreover they
almost they don't have cattle so it's
hard for them to get the organic matter
that they need to to to produce compost
but what they have is a lot of
tourists okay 2020 they have a a drastic
reduction of the number of tourist but
now they rise again and they have even
more than before so it means that they
have a high demand for local resources
and a high waste
generation and this hotel company Garden
hotels that has been working in the
island for more than 30
years and this man howas begin to think
okay maybe we can do something
about waste management and organic
matter and
soils so what they did is okay we want
to offer to our customers organic I
going to pass this video and will give
you later they want to give you to the
to our customers to our CL clients
organic products but they have to be
local we want local organic products and
they didn't find it in in the market so
what they did is okay we have we are
producing more than 100 tons of food
waste per year in just in one of our one
of our
hotels so they take it during one month
October 2016 we take it to a
farm managed by people as also in risk
of social exclusion we teach them how to
make compost and during this year that
the last month of that year they produce
organic compost that they G gave to the
association of organic farmers of the
iseland and with that compost they
produce organic products for the hotel
during this this pilot project we take
them all the politicians all the
technicians from the local government so
they can see they can touch they can
smell they can see that it was possible
it was real and with that we could begin
the real project in September 2019 so
nowadays two of those restaurants and
the bigger two of these hotels and the
biggest restaurants in the island the
hotel collect the food was from those uh
those places and they take it to a uh
organic farm in the island that is not
far that 15 kilometers from the hotels
and here we have a very small composed
facility very
simple we we train the people in the
farm how to make compost
and they take all the measure all the
controls we have everything under
control at every moment to be sure that
they are managed the food waste
correctly and the farmer gives the hotel
organic products by the value of the
organic matter that they receiv there is
no money exchange here only products the
farmer receives organic matter and the
farmer gives organic products by the
value of the organic
matter and until now we have Pro
processed more than 400 tons of food
waste in this year and the content in
contaminants now is around
0.15% so it's really really good
material to be processed in this simple
system the process as I said is
monitored and all the data are collected
and uploaded to the cloud so we can see
immediately what is happening and we
have all the process under control this
project has received different Awards in
the in the last year and the hotel is
very happy because at the end this is
publicity for them so they don't they
don't care for the investment in in the
project because at the end you have the
the return of a very good image it's
always in the press and they create jobs
one of them for people social exclusion
we have develop some Machinery in the
island so nowadays they know how to make
this this kind of machiner that we don't
have it before and also the hotel create
a new company for the management of
green wastage of the iseland to produce
the bul material that they need for for
the compost so the main challenge we
have during this this time was to
convince the local Administration as
floran said this one of the challenge
and one of the specific uh Target of
this kind of projects they become
official waste management manager it was
difficult but they they did it
now they as I said they know how to
produce their own bulky material we
don't have providers for the Machinery
in the island and at the end now we
can't build it in the island so the
things are changing now in in baleric
Islands related to to this kind of
projects and Ron I just want to flag
that we just have a few more minutes so
that we can leave uh time for questions
okay okay so this was the last example
this is the in Canary Island and just to
point you this is an island with a very
difficult orography high mountains
volcano Etc and all the all the organic
wastes are were managed here in just one
point of the island and now we perform a
project where there is a lot of
decentralized composting all on the
island and we are planning to use two
composting facilities that are already
exist for the treatment of agricultural
wastage from bananas mainly so they
can't now include also food WS from
local uh Village local small village and
towns in the area so this one of the
projects we we are working with to
finish it uh the pro the problems with
the with this model is that there is not
a specific regulation in Spain for this
scale so it depends of the
interpretation for every uh responsible
from the technical of the public
administration uh only in Nar they
perform uh because of the project of
HOSA they develop a first regulation
that is based in administrative and
Technical conditions okay you have it
here so we make it simple to to can
build and perform this
facilities our main problem here is the
quality of the food waste because in
some
cases we don't know who's going to
control the food waste that the facility
receives and who's going to pay if the
farmer has to invest more money or more
equipment and have a a loss of the
quality of the compost so here this is a
problem now in Spain when we try to
promote this kind of
models and the need of professional
Technical
Training that it is essential as as
floran previously said okay we know that
Farmers know about composting but this
is a little bit different and more
intense supervision external Technical
Support also Florian explain it about it
this here is a very a research group in
the University of
uh of Miguel Hernandez in in Valencia
that they are doing a very amazing job
work about it the training and the
giving assistance to the farmers and to
guarantee that the process is all the
proc the service is given during the
world year so this is also one of the
cons that the model has so it is
important to consider it finally just to
commment that it's important that the
Ora sector can be the all the best
allies restaurants hotels censes
cafeterias they create they generate a
lot of food waste and very clean food
waste so it's very easy to transform
into a compost in a local
model so as I said this is the key
aspect for for the model at least here
at this moment in Spain there specific
regulation that we missed the guarantees
of the quality of the food waste the
Technical Training technical support
external support service guarantees and
the synergies that we can create with
Rea sector just to finish uh our
association that's called ferti AO has
create that developed h a community
composting uh guide a handbook to
promote the model and it has been
translated to different language it is
in English if you want it and also to
the to Bolivia and other
areas we also perform as a friend said
training courses just for looking for
that so farmers and other people could
be trained and also those kind of Tours
to show people to show politician
technicians for other countries and also
other part of Spain that those models
are are a reality but what they need to
do what they need to know to take them
to their countries to their to the
regions and to really implement it so
that's all and sorry if I took longer
that I I thought but I hope it would be
interesting for you thank you very much
for your attention and any questions
here you have me fabulous that was a
great presentation thank you Ramon um
and so now we're going to move into uh
questions and answers and uh I just love
the
combination of um your
presentations um I think the gold
standard in Austria what this could look
like and I love uh seeing in Spain which
I think is probably more similar to
where we are in the United States of of
something a little bit uh where we're
still striving for that gold standard so
thank you for for that and uh I loved
seeing the I think your presentations
both clearly Illustrated the benefits of
community scaled composting solutions
that can really be adapted to the local
conditions and local challenges and
local communities but also some of the
considerations and challenges at that
scale and the importance of um support
um for the farmer
for uh in you know implementing the
composting but then also for uh
educating the community on how to
participate so uh such great
presentations uh one of the questions
that I think we could posee to both of
you um you both mentioned the importance
of
um contamination or just the needing a
clean stream that will be composted at
this scale and uh the question from
participant was what is an acceptable
amount of
contamination and uh for
customers or people uh submitting their
uh food scraps to be composed in these
projects uh what are the consequences if
they
exceed the
limits so can you hear me yes yes very
good so uh if you allow I can uh start
with that because we have after now 30
years of experience again a very big
discussion there um we are going to
implement a a minimum requirements so a
limit with um 2% by weight of impurities
of
contaminants uh that is allowed to enter
the composting heat and there is another
threshold that they consider now 5% by
by
weight um that can enter the composting
facility but then you have to introduce
a purification separation equipment yeah
to take the impurities out but
there's
actually who will pay for it who will
analyze it if it's 5.2 or 2.3 or
whatever uh so it's it's really tricky
so the only thing you can do you can you
you um and that what was very very
successful in our case is to uh achieve
the commitment by the by the entities
who are responsible for the collection
that might be in the municipality that
might be the intercommunity association
so the waste management
association of a number of
municipalities that might be a private
company but at the end the private
company is contracted by the
municipality or by a local Authority and
in the bylaws of the contract it must be
clearly stated that they have to take
into account take care about the proper
education and the control of the bins
they collect so they have to Pro provide
a system how they do the controlling and
the communication about the Purity and
the quality of the feed stalker and the
food waste they collect and I think this
again starts with a very intensive
corporate um um communication and
identif ation with the system and then
you might succeed um you ask for the
threshold that would be acceptable at
the end I'm telling you it's
1% it's 1% we we shouldn't be shamed to
be quite stringent and very clear about
it because 5% which you will find in
some of the areas in in in the big
cities for instance it look it looks
like hell because it's mainly plastic
and 5% by by uh by weight is uh even in
the final product you will have these
fine plastic pieces which are uh end up
in microplastic which is the big debate
today yeah I absolutely agree with with
Florian more than 2% becomes a problem
in in this kind of facilities with so
simple because if not you have to invest
in equipments or you have to invest in
time of your of your workers open the
bags by hand taking out the Plastics so
it's at the end that's impossible it
means that you have to invest a lot of
money for the
Management Facility as F said less than
1% is the objective here buet here the
problem of course is at the end who is
responsible for those qualities so
that's what I said at the beginning the
Ora sector the hotels restaurants
something like that very very easy quite
easy to have it under control to teach
the people in the kitchen in the Halls
how they have to separate the food then
it's very easy to have a important
quantity of food waste that is almost
completely clean so I'm begin with that
and then begin to train to to raise the
awareness of the people of the citizens
of the politicians of the local
administration of of the importance of
the of the separation on source and then
you can go you can try to get a a b a
good quality food waste and then you can
think okay now I can I can extend the
model to more facilities or to do this
facility a bit a little bit higher
bigger yes great answers uh the
importance of of models uh Pilots that
that can be scaled up uh once the
systems are dialed in um so I'm just
flagging that it's almost 13 I'm
wondering if you uh Ramon and floran
would be willing to stay on for just a
few more minutes to answer some more
questions yes definitely no problem
fabulous okay so uh one question uh
directed at you Florian I think was for
an urban area um did you in your the
examp one of the examples you gave uh
was the
material sort of collected at a central
area where contamin was removed and then
it was sent on to Farmers who would
compost it or are there also examples
where the farmers have to
decontaminate but it's always both
because the decontamination in a central
facility in the city is
uh never
complete yeah so um so if you collect
from a city we have the problem that we
might be in the range of 2% and then
they have some screening and some
separation by Ballistic separation and
Separation by wind sifter by Separation
by a magnetic separator etc etc uh but
at the end um we had those problems that
the mixed and prepared feed stock
delivered to the farmers still was quite
contaminated but this is also due to the
fact that there was not a much not
enough commitment by this City by the
municipality and its co-workers to do
more about education work to the
household and to to put more effort uh
even even in the in the cleaning and
purification and separation activities
but at the end it was the it is the
responsibility of the central of the
municipality and the facility to deliver
uh a well well prepared uh raw fit stock
mix to the
farmers
great thank you for that
clarification now question for youon um
someone asked is there any competition
between composters and pig Farmers or
other animal Farmers I suppose to
participate in the composting
model models that you mentioned
unfortunately not uh it's really hard to
find uh some farmers at this moment that
they want to be bor in this kind of in
this kind of models we have found in in
some cases that they they really want
the compost but when you say okay but
you have to do it by yourself and we are
you are going to collect or you are
going to receive the the food waste and
then you have to transform it into
compost and they say no no no it's I
don't have time it's more complicated uh
it's going to be uh I have I'm going to
have a lot of controls from the
administration I don't want to to have
problems and at this moment for example
in in Pedra in that province that I said
they have a very intense program in in
community composting now the C the
provincial government has developed a
project uh to uh give uh some kind of
Health economical healths to any uh
farmer or Association of farmers that
were that will that could will to
collect or receive organic waste from
municipalities
around them so they want to to to give
money for the investment in the facility
or in the collection system and try to
promote this model because they they
tried it years ago and they didn't find
any farmer interested in that so it's
difficult hearing most of the farmers
are are still related to the mineral
fertilizers
and it's now it's this year with the
crisis in in energy crisis with
a tremendous rise of the cost of the
fertilizers that a lot of them now they
are looking for organic fertilizers and
they try to to find other sources but
until
now you you have to to take a lot of
time to to knock a lot of doors to find
fness that could be interested in the
M yes uh the the current crisis um
with uh prices of a lot of Commodities
but including um fertilizers is uh
something we feel even here in the US um
it's very important but hopefully it
also brings us back to the importance of
um and opportunities with um compost as
uh an amendment that can also reduce the
need for uh fertilizers synthetic
fertilizers it's a great Point um so
a question that this also leads me to is
um how do you balance supporting Farmers
to to get involved with this without
making it feel like they're being forced
or um by putting too much of the onus
of uh the responsibility of managing all
of the different pieces
of collecting the waste and processing
the waste and then Distributing the
compost at the end uh maybe this is
question more for for uh chor and
because I think ran you sort of touched
on it but if you have anything to add
I'd love to hear from you
too now the the the key is is a farmer
really interested in these humus and
compost
cycle so um and the second is does he
has a right location and does he has the
human resources and some of the
equipment he can provide and this has
then to be decided between the
municipality the respons or the entity
that is local entity that is responsible
for the waste collection or the for the
waste
management um uh so usually we we have a
sort of a concour so there is a uh uh
an article in the local
newspaper we are looking for a farmer
who is interesting to do the job and
then there are two or three Farmers
coming up and they are invited and then
we explain them what's coming up so what
would be their Duty and their their task
it could be
including the separate
collection collecting part or it's just
receiving the organic waste that it
collected by another by the municipality
or by a collection
company and
then he's doing the job of composting
from from the from the Gate of the
composting plant down to the marketing
and everything so it is a side job or an
additional job he has to become a
professionalist a professional compost
producer it's
nothing that he should do just by you
know
um in the late afternoon or in the
evening it must be clear that he needs
time for that to maintain the composting
PL of plant of a professional
level
um in that
case I can say um the key issue there is
not to find interesting Farmers but to
find the right
location and and uh to to sort out to
identify if the farmer has the capacity
to do the job in the right way and this
is a little bit uh an issue that has to
be taken into account at the beginning
but from that on if this is okay if I
talk about location the minimum we try
to achieve is at least 250300
meter distance from the next uh
settlement or residential area or
permanent residence or restaurant or
something like
that and then the local climate has to
be taken into account to prevent later
on you know all the problems and
complaints by the neighbors and so
fors if I understood your question
correctly I think so Ramon do you have
any insights to
share uh
all all the things that Florian said
absolutely agree with him just to add
that some cases that we found uh that
the farmers look for the model or could
be interested in the model because of
the compost as they said that it's not
easy to especially those Farmers that
are looking for organic farming and they
are performing organic farming they need
compost and they they here in Spain to
find a high quality compost that could
be labeled as organic is not easy the
the production is quite reduced so if
they find the opportunity to do it by
themselves and they they make the
numbers and they see okay it is possible
for me then it's a it's a good incentive
for for them in our
case yes compost is a a high quality
compost um is not always easy to come by
you have to consider it is an additional
income also but have to provide service
for that income so our gate fee for for
for taking over uh Organic Kitchen waste
is in in order to cover all the costs
including the revenue it's between 50 55
to 65 Euros per ton and that is needed
to do a professional job um this refers
to paved and sealed and professional
composting plants that are constructed
on a on a on a high level
um I I forgot to mention that up to 300
cubic meter uh of green waste only so
Garden Parkwest only in Austria it is
allowed to do the composting on open
ground even the Intensive rotting phase
the
first I I Tred to increase this uh this
threshold because we have found even if
it's 1,000 cubic meters per year uh it
wouldn't do any harm if you do a
uh a good job um it could be open ground
if if you are uh in a certain distance
from surface water from rivers or
whatever from a lake and you don't have
groundwater problems or a nearby well or
whatever but in normal cases even on
open ground the ground is capable to
carry your machines and so forth you can
do it up to a certain uh quantity
right okay well um just to get to a
couple more questions from from the
audience I would love to continue
talking about this um but maybe another
time um just to trying to compare it to
what I what we're seeing in the US um
there's just lots of questions that are
coming up for me but um a question a
clarification for you uh Ramon was in
the examples that you gave were are
there compost coming onto the farm to do
the composting and the farmers receive
the compost in the end uh or are the
farmers actually doing the composting
themselves I don't think I understood
the question you mean
they are the farmers in the examples
that you in some of the examples you
gave are they actually doing the
composting or is there a separate entity
that comes in and actually does the
composting on the
farm no no they do it but in all cases
they do it by by by themselves but in
for example in that with the hotels they
have external support uh by myself and
and others to teach them and if they
have any problem or any doubt they just
immediately pH me or send me an email to
see it's happening this what I can do
that that's all but they do it in every
all those cases they do it by by by
themselves okay well thank you for that
clarification um for you for and um
someone early on in your presentation
asked if you could clarify the need for
clay um uh adding clay into the
composting mix to create stable
humus yeah this is basic knowledge of
soil
formation lecture number
one that 10,000 years ago when the
glacier disappeared you have just send
and grabble and so forth and then uh 100
year 100 Year by 100 year uh the soils
were formed uh by a combination of
further degradation and weathering of
the mineral substance into the small
small pieces less than two
micrometer and when it's less than 2
micrometer in particle size of minerals
this is secondary minerals clay minerals
they become
um plastic how you call that
they can take up water yeah and they are
performed and constructed in layers and
they can take up and absorb minerals
like calcium pottassium and they have
also um an electric
load uh in the surface which is negative
and this combines now not only with
minerals like calcium magnesium
potassium Etc but also with degradation
compounds from the organic breakdown of
peptides and um um carbohydrates Etc
from assimilate from the plants that are
micro that are degraded by microbial
activity and those um micro molecules uh
also have in their outer layer uh a
positive
loading and this is connected now with
the surface of these uh secondary clay
minerals and they build a protection
layer around these we call it humi
compounds that we don't know exactly
what it is chemically speaking we we
have a guess yeah in our in in in our
workbooks
yeah um but at the end this clay
compound is very very important to
stabilize the
partly degraded and stabilized organic
um compounds from microbial
decomposition and this is this is the
basic knowledge and it is not taken into
account because of costs so big
facilities consider if they have to add
I don't know 10% by volume or by weight
what take what you want of clay clay
soil into the composting process this is
a lot of effort the need additional
storage uh area and this costs money but
at the end the stability and the quality
of the humus compound they produce is
less and this is a lesson we learned
from basic soil formation lectures
yeah thank you for that that was that
was taught uh by the pioneers of
composting in the 1950s already but it
was forgotten
most a long time yes it wasn't until I
had the opportunity to study with uh
some composters in Austria a few years
ago that I I heard of uh clay being
added so um hopefully we were are res
sharing some forgotten knowledge there
um so a final question for both of you
um and I'm going to make it a two-part
question um someone commented that it's
great that restaurants and hotels are
getting involved um in these efforts are
there grocery stores uh getting involved
too and are you aware of any examples
that use uh vermic
composting uh as the processing
technique is the stores in the first
example that I I use in those that we
the bers here in Spain yes they are
they're taking some organic wastage from
food wastage from groceries stores so
it's it's also possible it's that kind
of generators that could be really
welcome in this kind of of models as I
said the same that hotels and
restaurants it's quite easy to separate
it and have a good quality and with bmit
composting some for example the that
project in maor the end of the mation
process they do it with worms so they
perform ver composting at the end but
just for mation not at the beginning and
uh now we are working also in in another
facility Al very small that will part of
it will be the the production of of ver
compost so it's it's been really really
possible but it's much better to be sure
that everything is under controll you do
it after at least after the fermentation
stage of the composting
process that makes sense foran uh any uh
examples of either grocery stores being
involved uh um I assume they must be um
and then if You' know of any vermic
composting that's happening in
Austria you also the groceries
supermarkets Etc obliged to provide
separate collection usually they
contract a professional collection
company um so it's depends on the size
of the village and the groceries Etc if
they are involved in the uh agricultural
composting scheme where also the farmers
do the collection well they're involved
partly with these on Farm composting but
for the for the bigger Supermarket
chains I would say not so much but we
have big composting plants of course
that are run by Farmers up to 15 to
20,000 tons per year uh they they're not
providing the collection but they
receive if the grocery are involved in
the general separate collection scheme
run by the
municipality uh then
they have to implement the S separation
for the Organics and then it is included
also and V
composting there is only one
professional example and this
facility uh does uh exactly as Ramon
said a a maturation phase more or less
we could say so after uh I think it it's
six weeks of intensive high temperature
composting phase composting phase but
is uh in this case
only uh um uh green manure so means
grass clippings and alpha alpha Etc from
the farm manure and green waste so
garden and park waste is composted
without kitchen waste and that is then
fed to a very
professional um wormy Farm Compost Farm
with automatic
harvesting uh the the the the
warm uh the war compost and so forth I'm
teaching it for home composting
intensively in a very simple way because
with warm composting there's nearly no
need for turning if you do it in the
right
way um it can be done very simple with a
very simple performance with a simple
similar equipment as Ramon showed it
from from the compost boxes from the
community composting facilities just a
little box put a little bit on the top
and let the WMS do the job and in 10
days you don't see anything anymore from
the kitchen
B great yes we um we uh Advocate or
teach uh Worm Composting for the home
scale but we are we do see it in the
community scale as well so um fabulous
thank you both so much for staying
longer to answer some of those questions
I'm sorry if we didn't get to
everybody's questions but um I really
appreciate this opportunity to learn
from the models you have been involved
with in Austria and Spain uh floran and
Ramon and I just really appreciate your
time and uh thank you all for
participating good luck to everybody
thanks to you you're welcome okay thank
you and take care
everyone thank
you byebye
by by
[Music]
Ramon